Kelly is in Denver
hi Kelly welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi god peace be with you you too how can
I help so I needed talkin to about fear
and so I am single when I was married my
my husband was an accountant so he took
in vervain I've been singing for a long
time and I just never really learned
about money and so I I'm in baby step
two and I don't have the feeling yet of
being in control of it and I'm having a
hard time even though I've paid off some
of my debt I'm having a hard time
letting go of the money so you have some
money in savings above $1,000 that you
should be throwing towards the debt and
you're having trouble doing that well
yeah it's not in savings it just kind of
hovers in my checking account and I'm
just afraid to let go of it so my
dollars invalid but I'm sorry how much
is in there well let's see months a
month I would say there's probably an
extra $500 like it's growing it's
growing which is good and what's your
household income about 50 okay how long
you been divorced 20 years oh okay long
time long time ago okay so it's also
hard for me I'm a team person so doing
this alone it's just intimidating money
is intimidating to me I understand okay
well you know what that makes you smart
actually because if you don't know how
to handle something that's powerful it
should be intimidating to you the first
time I got in a car and I was like 12
years old my dad threw me the keys and
we're out on the farm and he's like go
for a drive with the pickup through the
it was intimidating it's crud right
first time you drove a car it was
intimidating right right but after years
of practice you've increased your
expertise and confidence and there's no
longer any fear associated with it
agreed yeah so it's good fear it's wise
fear to be intimidated by some
that you can't handle well that's
powerful and so the trick is that
doesn't mean you never learn to drive a
car it just means it's a normal human
reaction the first time or two you drive
a car that it's intimidating is that
fair
so what this means is it's time for you
to learn to drive the car that's all it
means and you don't have to learn it
today but you need to learn start
learning it today and would you expect
to be more confident five months from
now than today you better five years
from now a lot more it ought to be
second nature just like driving a car is
second nature and so we get better at it
so that the intimidation goes away but
when you're beginning a task with a
powerful thing that you don't know how
to handle its wisdom to be intimidated
is that fair yes I hadn't thought of it
that way and so this is something that's
bothered you you've always said things
like I'm not a math person my husband's
and I can't my ex-husband 20 freaking
years ago is an accountant well he's not
even in that didn't even come into
anything but you've said stuff like that
that allowed you to kind of stay in this
thing where I'm not I'm not gonna
address the issue but now something's
prompting you to address the issue
that's why you called me and I think
it's wonderful it's a time of growth for
you Kelly this is a wonderful time for
you you're going to get better at
handling money and the fear as a result
is going to dissipate is that logical
yeah you're gonna do it I know you are
good and you you know you mentioned God
in your opening to me and so if you're a
person of faith then we're called to
manage steward is the old English Bible
word everyone throws around right to be
stewards right is that right yes we are
and so you know I want to be found a
trust worthy steward I want to be worthy
of trust and that means I've got to get
better at it oh by the way Dave Ramsey's
better at it than he was 20 years ago to
Dave Ramsey's better at it than he was
five years ago and meanwhile I've been
teaching everybody else and I'm still
getting better so I know things today I
didn't know
five years ago about this particular
subject and about other subjects too so
that's what I would tell you to do
you're gonna be great at it have you
ever been through Financial Peace
University no I've just recently heard
about it I hope your total makeover book
but beyond that I don't know a lot won't
you go to this class I'll pay for it
yeah I'll give it to you and I want you
to go the class because what that's
going to do is it's going to put some
people around you that are encouraging
that are also on the same journey and
they kind of normalizes the fear that we
feel sometimes the condemnation we feel
around money sometimes some of us I
screwed up so bad I had a lot of shame
about money I'm very cynical about money
people and you know all of those things
are and negative emotions that are
usually due to a lack of knowledge yeah
no thank you
cool you hang on and I'll have Kelly
pick up and we'll get you signed up for
the class it's nine weeks long one night
a week for nine weeks it'll be one in
your area and we'd love to have you go
as our guest